reopening Johnny Depp's X-Files welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight Kevin
Frazier has his birthday off today now
court is not in session today with
closing arguments beginning a week from
now and after Ellen barkin's bombshell
testimony we're breaking down who of
Johnny's former Flames our team death
and who isn't it
this one really does have the romance in
the fairy tale
this guy was sweet and loving and
romantic
he's just a jealous man controlling
where are you going that's how Johnny
holding up are you and John getting back
together I think in Johnny's Corner
Winona Ryder and Vanessa parodies both
were in long-term relationships with the
actor and both provided witness
statements during his UK trial saying he
was never violent or abusive we've been
married for years don't tell anybody
Winona's name actually came up in a
pivotal Court moment Johnny testified
how after their 1993 split he changed
his tattoo that said Winona Forever I
took off the last two letters
um and had it say why no forever
Amber testified she laughed when she saw
it I just laughed because I thought he
was joking
and
just let me cross the face
as for team Amber well according to
Legal expert Jesse Weber former flame
Ellen barkin's testimony yesterday was a
win for her side Mr Jeff threw a wine
bottle across the room now this is
important because it's a corroborating
witness to Amber heard's abuse
allegations it's also important because
Johnny Depp testified that he had never
been violent with any woman in the past
nice to meet you so it's not confirmed
that Kate Moss will testify but if she
does testify the allegation being that
Johnny Depp threw Kate Moss down the
stairs when the two are in a
relationship all I can say about that
trial is that it breaks my heart
for everybody involved Jennifer Gray was
engaged to Johnny for nine months during
the late 80s in her Memoir out of the
corner she called him crazy jealous and
paranoid but she told us she's grateful
for their relationship which started
after her breakup with Matthew Broderick
I was in desperate need of rebounding
into 1989 Johnny Depp trust me I was
bleeding out inside and this guy saved
me
now if you guys aren't watching the
trial on our YouTube channel get into it
we have it every single day you're not
going to miss a thing
foreign